if you could go back 10 years ago or 15
years ago and give yourself two pieces
of advice it would be buy bitcoin and do
531 with progressive overload as your
training program for the next 12 years
you'd be massive and rich the challenge
is what's the 45 year old version of you
what's that piece of advice for now do
five three one probably probably
probably probably just by bitcoin by
bitcoin
[Laughter]
how was christmas did you do anything
interesting
so i just did this was my first
christmas not in a hospital which was
nice so
just spent some family time i did all
the christmas man things cranberry sauce
turkey wrapping paper all of this
did you carve the turkey
turkey did the special say grace to
santa at the beginning
that's right isn't it is this what is
this what someone who's muslim thinks
that white people do this is what white
people do at christmas they pray to the
turkey and then you have the star which
is hezbollah and he sits on the top of
the tree
[Laughter]
and you have to say grace
everybody does bad dance moves
uh and invades a country and then you're
allowed to eat yeah and then no that's
you that's your people
that's
that's what you you guys do
is this your first experience of a
christmas celebration
or have you had more than this i think
one of
yeah first one it's one of everybody's
though isn't it true i think it was the
highest santa rating of all the
christmases that i've had like
really full
full beans yeah
somehow
none of the food the food items do not
have anything to do with santa i need
you to get you need to separate these
two things out
santa and the food items
come from three i like it the three
separate the food is a bit rubbish as
well like christmas cake
no if it was nice it would be available
for sale the rest of the year
no that's ridic you can't say that you
could like for example easter eggs
easter eggs are nice
but they're not for sale for the rest of
the year cream eggs are
available all year round because they're
just a different shape of
hang on
cream eggs are available all year round
yes they're the one they're the one type
of egg outside of the egg world the
legitimate egg world along with mindy
eggs
actually yeah mini eggs are also
available it's quite easy
so i feel like we've talked about this
before but there's a guy online who made
so he bought an easter egg creme egg
and he was disappointed because it was a
hollow
large
chocolate with little cream eggs inside
and he was like no no no i can't be
having this so he bought 37 small creme
eggs and made a solid
easter egg probably weighed about two
kilos yeah oh yeah absolute diabetes but
you did it so
johnny what did what did you do
not much
really
i went to my parents
i pray to santa
and
and uh
yeah
very quite quiet christmas actually it
was quite nice do you get anything cool
do you get any nice presents
no
socks
socks
yeah i think once you cross 30 that's
what the president's become yeah isn't
it and you you're actually a bit pleased
about all of them as well the saddest
thing is that is the joy that you take
from thinking i don't need to buy shower
gel for the next couple of days
i got i got four by 500 mils of shower
gel this year two liters of shower gel
if you do
christmas
condiments not condiments what's the
word
yeah
there's a word beginning with con
something
uh
confectionary ah what is it people
listening to like toilet
toiletries
you do them by the gallon are they all
are they all tresemme
this is a story this is a story because
i tried to transport two liters of
tresemme shampoo to iceland when we were
traveling over there and
we had to dump them in a bin chris took
a a hair salon worth of hair products
in his suitcase
and then wondered why it was over the
limit for weight
yeah the lady they edinblady wasn't
happy was she how was your christmas
other than getting
a lot of shampoo good man i got
i i've eaten a lot i've had i'm
surprised i didn't pb in the gym today
because there was a lot of calories
behind those lifts
an awful lot a lot of swelling yes yeah
extra extra water yeah very much so it
was good it was good i got a new
backpack i got some cool [ __ ] that i've
been after for a little while and
i fell asleep at like 7 p.m every day
just a classic british christmas you
know just
phasing in and out of consciousness
based on where your blood sugar's at
and then as you did as you dip down
you realize that you've fallen asleep
again and you wake up you you wake up
watching fantastic beasts or whatever
where to find them yeah that's a very
good summary i
the the falling asleep thing's weird
because
even after a night of like eight and a
half hours
it still gets like 6 30 yeah i'm still
sort of like loading off on myself yeah
but you're also not used to having over
200 grams of sugar
in a single day that's true in a single
in a bowl a single meal yeah yeah that's
true i believe the word was cosmetics
yes
i can relax
at the start of a podcast as well you'd
be like the whole time
chris would be like well what's your
lesson for the year for like [ __ ] it
i don't know i've got no lessons
uh okay so we're going to do
lessons from 2021 a couple of lessons
that we've taken away each i did a big
400th episode
19 lessons from 400 episodes the reason
that it was 19
nothing special about that but we can go
through some of the things that we've
taken away from this year also if
anybody wants to do an end-of-year
review and hasn't done yet they can go
and get my template which is free
chriswilex.com review it's the exact
process that i follow and i think you do
as well seth i think it's the same one
that you use every year to kind of round
out the lessons from the previous year
and then
set some plans and goals and stuff like
that for what's coming up so i guess
some of the things that we talked about
today may have been brought out by that
but i haven't done mine yet so i still
need to do my end of year review so
johnny i've actually done it every year
since last year
wow
[Laughter]
wow wow indeed if that's not the
testimonial that i've always wanted
there we go
uh johnny what have you got what's your
first lesson from 2021
there's the hot potato there it is fresh
out the oven
um
so
the
i have actually done my end of year
review like a like a good boy because i
thought that would be that's the whole
point of this episode but
no problem
um
i think uh
i i mean i might have said this on a
life hack before but the just the idea
of like
taking something away so if you i think
a lot of people who listen to these
episodes i imagine probably do or try
and do a lot of things whether it's like
personal development or hobbies or if
you run a business you're probably
trying lots of different stuff if you're
trying to like build a build your own
podcast or or do similar to what we do
in propane you've got like a lot of a
lot of things that you're trying to
juggle
um
and i think
it's very hard when you're doing a
review process like this and planning
the next year to think oh well because
you naturally just think i want to do
more of all of it
and get all of it all of it better and
hit pbs and all of it
but it's very hard to know whether any
of it's working so stuff that i've done
throughout this year some of it's forced
some of it's not forced was stopping
doing a few things and i think you
either realize
just how much of an impact it has and
you're even more convinced on it like
more convincing you ever be or you're
like actually you know what i stopped
that and i didn't really notice anything
so two examples to me from that were
um
when i
um so i didn't train when i had covered
or
i had a cult like a really bad cold
in december didn't train again
both times like because sometimes i
think like i'll be nice to have a month
off training it'd be nice to have a
better time where i don't have to go to
the gym
but when i force start training you
realize just how many things and you
said this before chris just how many
things did impact you um stopping
meditating for a while realizing how
much of an effect that has when you
don't do it
but for example things like a gratitude
journal or journaling in general
when i stop doing that i don't notice
that much
um so
taking things away and then there's
loads of examples on the business side
as well stuff we've stopped this year
like we stopped the podcast
and only when we started getting people
saying like where's the podcast have we
decided to bring it back in again um so
yeah just
testing something whether something's
actually helping or not by
practicing not doing it for a while
batting yourself from just like an
elimination diet but for your daily
productivity system
yeah or anything um
like even as has done like certain
exercises or like try not squatting for
a while see what happens see if you
notice anything for example
um
yeah well we never know right this is
this is a [ __ ] thing you never know
what is contributing to your success or
failure in life until you start to take
things away because if you add stuff in
and this is always the problem whenever
someone says oh man you you really look
like you've made great progress in the
gym during the first quarter of this
year what is it that you've done that's
caused that progress and you're like bro
i have no idea i did ten things
i did i did a bunch of different things
my diets changed my sleep's changed my
programming's changed this has changed
or it's what you did in q4 the year
prior and
yeah
it's worst nightmare stopping doing
things that are working forever terrible
but yeah so um first lesson is
um
i think when you're planning next year
pick one thing to deliberately stop
doing for a while so especially if it's
something you're not quite so i think
we've all got that thing in that like
morning routine or life where we're not
quite sold on it but maybe do it because
we think we have to
just try not doing it like for example i
tried
not tracking my calories while i was
dieting for a period of time this year
to see if i could get away with it
and i can't
categorically know some people can some
people can and i listen i listened to
this podcast it was so convincing it was
with eric helms and a dietitian they
were like not tracking is way better
than tracking just eat by feel basically
yeah that sounds so much better tried it
for a month gained weight was like right
lesson learned yeah back to tracking
yeah
it it really depends on because i think
we're all we're probably front running
chris's uh lesson for
for the year actually because i know you
mentioned this when i saw you last last
week
but
i guess it depends on do you value the
progress or do you value the lesson more
and that's i guess short versus long
term so as you say if you're doing a
training program that is just throwing
the kitchen sink at it and hoping that
you get big
you might be happy with the fact that
you got big and not really wonder about
whether it was the split squat so
whether it was the the lateral raises or
whatever but as johnny says like
if you're interested in continuing to
make progress it's useful to know which
part of it
was helpful and which part wasn't so
it's a
i think it's in
software design they call it like
exploit versus explore is that right
something like that so you go through
like a phase where you're like trying to
find your like your best of
and then putting all of your resources
into the best of rather than it being
more diffuse
because you've already got so many units
of like time energy attention
yeah it's nice to say like oh let's just
do the maximalist approach just do
everything hard all of the time and
you'll make progress but um you know the
the book recommendation from last year
chris essentialism
um is a book that i think i'm going to
need to read a few times and it covers
johnny's
lesson there called the negative pilot
where
you take something that you're doing and
you say right i'm going to actively not
do that and see what happens and i
suppose that's similar to what you were
saying about
choose what you're going to suck at or
choose oh man yeah so
johnny is you've been saying that one of
the lessons that i have this year
overlaps with what you're talking about
and then one of the ones that just
didn't make today's list but now has
made today's list because you've
basically brought it up oliver berkman
who wrote 4 000 weeks
he says in advance of making goals you
need to choose what you're going to fail
at because a lot of the time when you
decide to focus your attention on
something inevitably that takes your
attention away from other things then as
you notice that those other areas start
to slip you feel the fomo and you think
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] i know that i said
that i was going to focus on uh getting
into a relationship or socializing more
with my friends but i've noticed that my
condition's dropping because i'm not
going to the gym as much or i'm not
making as much money because i'm
spending more more cash
on nights out and stuff like that so
then you alter your perspective and you
start to try and just do everything at
once the fear of losing gains in certain
areas mitigates your ability to focus on
one area in any case and that that's
like it's so hard to let that go because
we want as you say that maximalist
approach everybody's looking for yeah i
know i know like the normie npc version
of this is that i need to focus and i'm
going to have to let some areas fall
behind but how do i get everything at
once it's like no you you can't do that
you can't really lose fat
and gain muscle and get a girlfriend and
save for a house and you know you can't
do all of these things at once what is
the what are the priorities that you
really really care about it's exactly
like you look at people and you go oh no
that's just recommendation for for the
break you know that's the suggested
serving size no i don't know bollocks to
that i mean i mean i made the whole
thing
yeah on the whole [ __ ] box yeah man i
mean my to run off the back of that one
johnny my first one is a quote from john
maxwell which summarizes greg mcewen's
essentialism perfectly you cannot
overestimate the unimportance of
practically everything
and that's john maxwell
twister of a quote
can you say that again
you cannot overestimate the unimportance
of practically everything
you cannot not underestimate no
unimportance of not actually look you're
confusing everyone stop it stop it
you're being you're down in surrey and
you know that i can't get to you
that's haram um
so yeah my realization for this year is
that the ultimate productivity system is
to get really clear about what you want
and then to ruthlessly cull everything
else
like if you really really want to make
progress in a particular area
just
forget about the other things forget
about the fomo forget about the failure
and that oliver berkman thing plays a
part of this right like choose what you
want to suck at so for me this year i
really really wanted to rehabilitate my
achilles and to get my lower back into a
place where it's super super stable and
i can start to build a good training
program in 2022 so i knew that my
condition was going to drop this year
i'm not okay i'm probably gonna look a
bit shittier than i usually will do and
maybe my life to my strength and maybe
training is gonna be a bit boring but
okay like when i notice that when that
arises and i think oh i don't look as
big or i'm
my lifts aren't as strong or training
sucks a bit that's the price that's the
entry price that i was prepared to pay
in order to make the progress i wanted
to make
and it helps to mitigate
that short and long-term thing as well
it helps to keep you in a long-termist
mindset it's like look
you would you wouldn't have a problem
with dieting for one week before you go
away on holiday but talking about doing
a rehabilitation plan for an entire year
so that your training for the next five
years can be really really strong
there's there's like a time discounting
problem that we have with that right you
just think it's so long it shouldn't
take this long but you go look the body
takes a fair bit of time to recover so
yeah you cannot over overestimate the
unimportance of practically everything
the ultimate productivity system is to
get really clear about what you want and
then to ruthlessly cull everything else
and the only way that you can get really
clear is to do something like an end of
year review to look at what what are the
lessons i've learned from this year what
are the single goals that i want health
relationships career and personal growth
like the four areas just single north
star for each of those and if you got
those by the end of the year
you would be so buzzing with your
achievements because there's going to be
tons of downstream things that you can't
predict in any case you don't need to
say oh i want to learn a new skill or
try a new sport because you're just
going to do that as a byproduct of
existing you know that doesn't need to
be on the list it's like what's the real
real big change that i want to make the
forcing function change and uh yeah
that's it's so funny how um
both of our lessons
for this year have been to do with
taking more away rather than adding more
in
yeah i think um that feels just like the
phase we're at though like you know i
think you you go through it when you go
through any sort of personal development
journey i think the first phase of it is
just doing absolutely everything and
adding adding adding and you end up with
a five hour morning you end up with most
of your day being your morning routine
right and then you're like hang on a
second
this is ridiculous
yeah i've got i spent half an hour
sorting my spreadsheet to track my sleep
data that's been output by my whoop and
my aura ring to make sure that i yeah
that's definitely well actually i could
have just slept another 30 minutes yes
yeah precisely
precisely yeah it's um do you think you
know how girls that spend lots of time
together they're period cycles their
menstrual cycles tend to align do you
think that we have productivity cycles
that have aligned because of the same
reason
i would say so that's real science as
well right that's not
bro science real science doctor approved
thank you that your productivity meso
cycles align i'll line up
[Laughter]
and you also you're more productive when
it's the full moon because
oh i certainly are gravitational pull on
the the lunar energy
because of chakras yes
uh so that's mine yousef what you got
so this actually leads on to
very nicely um this one but
you have to do the negative pilot stuff
first you have to
know what you're exploiting before you
do this tip so if you're not doing that
do negative pilot pause the podcast
now
before we
eliminate everything
yeah
what it is that you should be doing
usually the first thing that comes up is
oh well i i don't have time to be doing
that thing and we know from
the the last few chats we've had we
always kind of circle back to screen
time
is that usually if you say you haven't
got time to do something and you look at
your screen time and you see how many
hours you're
binging away on stupid apps
you you probably do have the time
so then
the next question is
rather than try or the next thing to do
is rather than trying to increase your
reading speed or how efficient your
training is or how high quality your
meditation is by using your binaural
beats and your infrared helmet and all
this stuff sometimes you don't need the
life hack you just need to do more of
the thing that you know that you should
be doing
and
i think
sometimes the mindset of
maximizing the speed and things
means that we end up actually cutting
corners on just the total volume of time
that we spend doing something give us an
example
so trying to listen to the i'm so guilty
of it listening to things on two or
three times speed
and therefore spending less time
actually listening to something
rather than saying no i'm going to
dedicate an hour and a half two hours to
actually get through a book or
you know rather than trying to use the
muse headset and the biofeedback and all
that but no i'm i'm better off
meditating for 40 minutes a day
than trying to get like 10 minutes of
pristine quality meditation or you know
um people do it with training quite a
lot as well like you know you see the
guy come in with this compression um
occlusion occlusion training and
all these kind of advanced techniques
but
he's not he's missing 20 of his sessions
so
the the overarching theme there is
really stop trying to perfect your form
if you aren't actually doing the reps in
the first place obviously both are
important but
quantity and quality
are both needed and if you let one slip
then
you're losing a big side of the equation
so like reading
about meditation versus just using that
time to meditate
so yeah i read so many books about
meditation when i look back on them like
a lot of them were saying kind of the
same thing and it's difficult because
you know there are there's the
occasional book that you're like whoa
that was a game changer that's really
leveled it up and
you know what was one of those books for
you
so for
the standard v passenger mindfulness
meditation i think mindfulness in plain
english is very good
for concentration meditation ajahn
brahm's
book called mindfulness bliss and beyond
i think even though it's not about
mindfulness it's about the other side of
meditation
is fantastic
cool
so um one of the just the kind of top
quote from that was
that
enlightenment comes from the soaring
summits of silence within
nice
i don't know what it means but it's nice
it's nice
sounds great yeah i am i think that
it is a blending between those two right
and chris sparks a couple of years ago
said to us in order to pick something up
you have to put something down
so when you're thinking about adding
stuff into your productivity system or
your daily routine or your habits or
your life for next year
you have to presume that the amount of
time that you spend being productive is
the amount of time that you have
if you just think oh i'll add this in
and i'll down regulate my sleep or
upregulate my efficiency to be able to
fit in
playing rugby you know joining a rugby
team and training two nights a week on a
saturday
a massive one you know people will have
like all the sleep kit and then like the
ben greenfield magnetizer for your
mattress and the the sleep mask and all
this stuff but they're doing six hours
they'll be in bed for six hours yeah
precisely go to [ __ ] bed for a little
bit longer
yeah jesus yeah that's good
i had an experience this was like years
ago with eric helms my coach saying to
me he banned me from asking him any
questions about car backloading and carb
timing
because it was like if you you cannot
send me a message an email asking me
about carb timing while you are hungover
like you are completely missing the
point
when like you've missed today's training
session you're because you're hungover
and you're asking me about timing your
carbs like there's a layer it's kind of
like this is like a keep it simple
stupid
approach right stop [ __ ] sweating the
small stuff we know a guy
johnny and i who is is huge and if he's
listening he'll know who he is
we saw him in the gym and johnny was
chatting to him about his training
program and it turns out he's just done
five three 531
for
several years but wasn't that what you
said on the life hacks a little while
ago if you could go back 10 years ago or
15 years ago and give yourself one piece
of advice it would be oh sorry two
pieces of advice it would be buy bitcoin
and do 531 with progressive overload as
your training program for the next 12
years you'd be massive and rich
you'd have a pretty good
time in your 30s wouldn't you
the the challenge is what's the what is
the like 45 year old version of you
now like what's that piece of advice for
now do five three one probably probably
probably probably yesterday
by bitcoin
[Laughter]
i should have just done five three one
the whole time what was it doing uh
right johnny what you got what's number
two god damn it
um
so this is i think this is something
i've heard you talk about before you
might have even done a video on this
chris but um
just the the whole thing of like
make every year when you make progress
or you hit a new milestone or it's all
numbers really isn't it generally like
achievements things that happen
um
and they generally feel the same like i
think especially money feels the same
it's like this year in in propane we've
hit like
new arbitrary milestones that have
always wanted to hit or you know you hit
a new low weigh-in or a new pb in the
gym
um and i was saying this to becca like
it's getting to the end of the year
we've hit the targets we wanted to hit
financially but i feel just the same way
as i did last year and the year before
and the year before when i do this
review process of like but what's the
next
thing
um
and
unless you're like
10 to 100x your personal income your
life's gonna be pretty much the same
next year
um there's a quote it's a something i
heard paul moore say
which is i've never heard it i've heard
like this idea before but never heard a
phrase like this that the outcomes you
hit are the
the rewards you get for running your
system or for pressing play on your
system so like if you're just running
this process all the time you'll
naturally just hit these
arbitrary numbers and milestones
um
and so i think the
the the lesson of the thing that i
always come back to when i look at this
stuff is trying to
just accept that like certainly the way
i'm wired i think a lot of people are
wired is just by like little mini wins
like little bits of progress are really
all that matter so setting something
that you quite like doing on a day or a
week and then just care just care about
the mini wins and almost forget about
the like it's so hard at this time of
year isn't it because everyone's like i
really want to hit
i want to get that promotion or i want
the next
milestone whatever that is
um and you forget about the like when
you step on the scales and hit a new way
in for the week that doesn't matter
because it's not the big number but
actually
it's really all that matters if you just
stay motivated
about that
thing is that you never
you never want to believe people that
say that that have actually been there
so
because you always go oh no when i hit a
million i'm like i'm definitely
gonna be happy oh yeah it didn't make
him happy but that's kids whatever
like i remember watching yeah i remember
watching ali abdel talk about
when he first hit his million
subscribers and million million dollars
revenue for the year and
and he was you'd always talk very flatly
about you know it's just hidden
adaptation like actually i was probably
most happy when i first hit my
500th subscriber because that meant so
much to me at the time and when i hit a
million it was kind of like oh yeah well
here we go or when i hit a million
pounds
and
yet for some reason you look at that and
you go
yeah like i'll be different it's stephen
bartlett has a story about that that he
brought up on the podcast he was saying
the day that social chain got sold for
some terrifying amount of money he was
less excited than when he found 19
pounds down the back of a chicken shop
seat
because
his hedonic adaptation had kicked in and
yeah it doesn't really matter how many
times you hear this story you don't want
to believe that it's true but man it's
so [ __ ] true it touches on a bunch of
different things that i that again
didn't quite make my list but uh
like unbelievably important celebrating
little wins giving yourself the um
allowing yourself to actually have a
celebration so me and dean got when we
hit 100k we got balloons and we took
photos it's a dumb thing
but that we wanted to do it it made us
feel really [ __ ] good and you're like
yeah that's a thing that's a memory now
we did it we worked really really hard i
hit this goal and before i decide to set
myself the next one and start obsessing
about what's coming next
morgan housel has a quote in the
psychology of money where he says the
number one thing that you need to do to
win the game is to stop moving the goal
posts further away from you every single
time that you hit a new financial goal
you then move the goal posts further
away ben hardy that's nice and then
quickly straight away benjamin hardy in
the gap in the game which is the gap in
the game by ben hardy's brand new it's
only come out about a month and a half
ago it's 160 pages you can read it in a
weekend or you can listen to it and it
exclusively talks about this problem and
he says that setting goals in this sort
of a way is like running toward the
horizon
that every single step that you take
your goal moves the same distance away
from you and
the problem is that we all love
the byproduct that we get out of this
that
that not fear of insufficiency but that
constant desire for more motivates us
and continues to get us to move forward
but
like one of the lessons or the lesson
that i had that didn't make the list
which is now making the list
is
is that the outcomes that you're going
to get in life are going to come along
for the ride in any case
fearing about whether or not you're
going to get them is a [ __ ] pointless
exercise that just annihilates your
enjoyment in the moment like you are
going to get to the place that you're
going to get to based on the skills that
you have and the work that you put in
and the people that are around you and
support you and really that's probably
not going to change if you decide to
fret and be anxious and be really really
concerned about what's coming next and
constantly think about what you're going
to feel like when you hit this next goal
or if you just do the thing there is no
difference between the man that obsesses
over the thing and does the thing
it probably doesn't help
it'll probably negatively impact your
performance yeah
well that so that's the thing that was
kind of attached to this which is just
that ironically the
i have fat like this is a bit woo with
this this is something i've spoken to
lunar energy
but lunar energy exactly no um
yeah but
the as soon as you kind of
i find as soon as you like accept that
like oh yeah the numbers arbitrary it
doesn't matter you just hit it anyway
and actually it's easier to hit that way
and and this has happened so
consistently to me that i almost don't
even want to acknowledge it for fear of
accepting the woo the
the chi or something but like
the the more you just like oh yeah i'll
just how do i just like
do all the things i need to do today and
forget about everything else
then oh oh [ __ ] i've hit this new
target that i had six months ago and
i've not even really thought about it
since then
um but yeah the more you kind of worry
about it
like if you're looking for something in
the house and you're like i know
someone's smart alex can be like oh well
it's always in the last place you look
because then you stop looking but what i
mean is
you you're looking for something and
then you're like ah you know what forget
it and it's and then immediately it
turns up there's something to do with
the ease and the grace that you go
through life with for doing stuff like
that i think this is a big part john
viveki this year on the show really
reminded me the importance of an
embodiment practice getting out of your
head just getting into sort of just
feeling
the way that life is for and johnny
wilkinson on that high performance
podcast he's saying find joy in the
present moment you know washing the
dishes is no more or less important than
winning the world cup final because if
it's less important that means that i am
less important as a human when i'm not
playing rugby am i less important now
than i was then no i'm not so that's
that pushes the the woo and the the like
lunar energy even further than you
johnny but
i don't know i i think
i think you saw's laughing because for
about a week yusuf thought that johnny
wilkinson was wayne rooney
did you remember that
wayne rooney is a really good i think in
my head when you say the word johnny
wilkinson a picture of wayne rooney
comes up in my head
and i was thinking wow he's so erudite
and so thoughtful and and doesn't mean
at all
i'm sure you said to us chris like
listening to johnny wilkinson you said
listen to it he's like wow and then like
is this johnny wilkinson the photo of
wayne rooney i don't remember that like
sports not my thing but i know that's
not johnny wilkinson
[ __ ] hell yeah man i think that's
that's like a an absolutely mega lesson
whatever it is that you're trying to do
the outcomes are probably going to be
the outcomes that you're going to get
and fretting and annihilating yourself
and being neurotic about it on route to
doing it changes
literally [ __ ] all
about the outcome except maybe
negatively impacting it and it ruins the
entirety of your journey up there the
analogy that um
ben hardy has is he says you're climbing
a mountain
99.9 percent of the climb is the climb
and only 0.1 is you standing on the top
of it but do you want to really hate all
of that bit up there because you're
terrified about the prospect of not
making it to the top of the mountain
but but equally like no one summits
everest by accident do they like that i
just go oh yeah i'll just have a crack
at that like how hard can that be like
they have a plan and execute it in the
way that they
are very consistent did you watch nims
purges documentary that 14 peaks thing
[ __ ] the bed you watched that surf
no worthwhile really really good
hard bastard
crazy
uh gurkha x special boat service
uh special for british special forces
guy
uh holds the record for the highest the
14 highest death zone mountains in the
world so the 14 mountains that are above
8 000 meters and the previous record was
six and a bit years and he does
all 14 in eight months he does one of
them on a with a stonking hangover like
the worst hangover that anybody can
believe in and then he does three of
them in 48 hours he just like the three
of them in pakistan gets this weather
window and does k2
which is the second highest and
something else and something else and
all of the climbing community are just
they gobsmacked they can't believe that
this guy is a complete freak the one
that he does with the hangover is the
most egregious
of the lot
something about
just missing a chip in their brain for
fear
no for you
there's so i
two years ago went up hell vellum
right which is basically a vessel
comparably
thanks
so that's 3000 feet tall
right what's up the height of
950 meters
okay so so eight and a bit times that
yeah okay so
i climbed up half valen and honestly
for days afterwards was wiped
like it i thought it was going to be not
that bad it was
really difficult like people listening
and laughing i wasn't i'm not
cardiovascularly in the best condition
possible but my god is that harder than
you think and then i watched this guy do
like on consecutive days
something like eight times that
and the best bit was when he's there's
like all those climbers
the the climb is like round the
base camp of one of these mountains
going we can't do that we can't do that
the weather's too bad when he arrives
and just like yeah
yeah yeah yeah and then the next morning
just does it anyway
i just completely ignore them yeah man
be sick right seth what have you got
what's your next one
so mine is just
it doesn't get easier you just get
better
i think
we
expect when we hit certain
milestones
that
you'll somehow
like life will get easier as well but it
just just changes the whether it's
because we're changing the goal posts or
just because you're just
hit with new bouts of
problems and qualitatively different
types of admin at different stages
and
i suppose that
um
relates to if you if you're building a
business for example like uh the
problems that you would have in a 100
000
pound business are very different to
what you'd have in a 10 million pound
business
or 100 million pound business
it's not necessarily that it's easier
just because there's more money just
because you've achieved what you think
is the
the metric that you're going for it's
just that
the types of problems change
has
somehow
somehow has a really really good bit on
this
where he says um people presume that one
day they're going to have fixed all of
their problems what did you think that
one morning you were going to wake up
and all of your problems would have been
solved like playing a video game and
arriving at a level where there's no
more enemies there's no more landscape
there's nothing to do yeah it's inbox
zero for your entire life no your
problems are going to be a part of life
you're always going to have challenges
how does it mean
what do you what's the difference
between getting better
and and
it being easier
so
for example if if you lift weights yes
like 100 kilos is gonna feel easier
but now the challenge is 200 kilos
and so and that feels just as hard if if
anything
probably more painful in some ways
because
your skin hasn't got thicker
your connective tissue isn't that much
but you know so
it's just that
as as you level up yes like what all
you've done is you've made yourself
stronger to deal with
bigger and bigger challenges and you can
coast you can you can stay out the
previous ones you know it's equivalent
to the guy who is just always benching
100 kilos never wants to increase it
because he's just he's happy doing that
fine all the power to you if you want to
do that but
um i suppose that
it's not a satisfying way to live life
if you're always well within your
capacity
ed cohen is famous for giving that
answer at seminars when people are like
what does it feel like it's quite a
thousand pounds and he just says well
what's your one rep max and i said 150
is like exactly the same as what it
feels like to squad 150. see isn't that
yeah so
yeah but like of course it is
but i suppose
it's just
get like learn to enjoy the frustrations
or learn to just accept the frustrations
and the
like whatever it feels like now is how
it'll feel at whatever level you're at
and it's always going to and so yeah i
suppose the two lessons there don't get
complacent but also don't expect to wake
up one day and be like oh right
everything's solved now and as i've gone
up a level
there's no new problems at this level
it's it's not going to be an empty level
it's a series of different problems all
right my one um so this was
uh a bit
less
uh productivity focused but just
opportunity cost is a mental model that
most people will be familiar with it's
by going to the theme park it means that
you can't go to the gym the cost of
going to the theme park is the fact that
you can't go to the gym there is a
choice between the two that's the
opportunity cost of you going to do a
thing so i
felt like there was a an equivalent to
do with uncompleted tasks uh so i called
it the anxiety cost
and i learned this by realizing that at
the start of every morning when you wake
up your daily tasks reset let's say that
every day you need to
walk the dog and meditate and answer
emails and do whatever right that resets
every morning as soon as you wake up
the time that you spend throughout the
day
up until you do that task
is filled with ruminative thoughts about
the fact that you still need to go and
do the task what that means is the
sooner that you can get that task done
the sooner you can feel relieved about
the fact that you no longer have to
think about it so the anxiety cost is
the amount of time that you take up
thinking about the fact that you haven't
done a thing let's say that it's
somebody's birthday coming up and you
know that you need to buy them a present
you could buy them a present right now
and never have to think about the fact
that you still need to buy them a
present or you can wait for the next
month and how many times are you going
to think about the fact that you still
need to buy them a present you can
mitigate you can negate and reduce the
anxiety cost by just doing the thing
that you need to do sooner rather than
later
we all know someone who at uni would
always leave the essays or the
dissertation until like the absolute
yeah
last minute
i so not not to blow my own trumpet or
anything but i
i got my dissertation in like probably a
month early and i remember people were
saying to me oh that you're so organized
or motivated or whatever and it's like
not really i'm just avoiding the pain
like i've got two types of pain i could
experience here either the anxiety cost
or the all-nighters well anxiety cost
and the all-nighters and stuff or the
trying to get it done a bit early and
you know you have long summers at uni
where
you're doing actually nothing
well that's just time that you could be
doing that like there's nothing special
about
that time where you can't be so
yeah it's
i don't think it's any more virtuous to
do one over the other it's just what
kind of pain do you want to experience
i think this all the time about like i
should just go to the gym in the
mornings
i have this honestly all the time like
it'll get to 4pm i'm like oh
god why didn't i train earlier yeah yeah
like i've got to do this big session i
could have just done it this morning and
now i could just continue doing the task
that i'm doing that i'd quite like to
finish when we have to stop because i'm
going to do my gym session but the
trouble is like you can apply that thing
that idea to everything
you have to do everything immediately
well yeah like i've got to write that
email i've got to make that
i'll do it all now
yes
yeah try doing nothing i've never taken
the negative pilot like level 10 like
the frozen turkey version where i just
do nothing ever and see what happens
yeah yeah okay now yeah i do get that
man i think i know
so we know a family friend who just
canceled all of his direct debits and
just waited people to get back in touch
with him because he looked through his
bank and he was like oh oh there's too
many and i don't know what goes where
just blank cancel
just blanket everything and he said
barely anyone got back in touch with him
so wow
he's probably got bayless coming to his
door now though but yeah taking a bit of
time yeah after a while they they get
the authorities involved don't they it's
um that anxiety costs a big deal but
you're right there's probably a limit to
what you should apply this to but with
things
with things that are easy fixes
if it's a short time investment the
choosing a birthday present for someone
is such a perfect example it's like look
it's gonna take you five minutes if it's
somebody you know just someone that you
need to get a little one for it's gonna
take you five minutes to choose a choose
a birthday present just [ __ ] do it
just do it now immediately
um
or paying a paying a parking fine
paying a parking fine especially because
the anxiety cost actually comes with a
legitimate increase after two weeks
in
the amount of money that you need to pay
so that's that's perfectly correct
that's how it should be if you leave it
for two weeks if you've left left the
anxiety cost in there
pay double your prick well then it
becomes a real cost yeah so there's
there's not that not just the anxiety
costs but there's the risk of forgetting
about the task just knowing in the back
of your mind oh there was something i
needed to do but i can't quite put
got a letter yeah no it's a [ __ ] quid
do it
johnny we got
is it right you said uh
it is me
so thank
god potatoes cooled down
so this is in relation to
the last couple of years but i think it
applies to to most stuff and i've been
really getting into a guy called zed dog
md it might be fun to get on the podcast
actually
zubin
damaya bro de mayo
dobrovska or something um
but he
went through the
the pandemic and the kind of
polarized
views on it and all of the sequelae that
we're seeing from how people
respond to it and we were saying the
other day chris that there seems to be
this weird tie-in now of like different
ends of the political spectrum
having
like
mixed in their views on
virology yeah i mean how how the [ __ ]
how the [ __ ] it is that far left and far
right have managed to agree on the same
thing which is that uh big the the large
farmer
at the top of the tree is trying to kill
everybody like what the [ __ ] do yoga
moms and populist right wingers have in
common oh they all hate big pharma now
apparently
yeah it's it's become kind of picked
into the actual identity and and i
remember seeing this
because i'm politically completely
apathetic and
i i like to think that i'm
quite evidence-based or at least
empirical with the way that i look at
things and obviously working as a doctor
as well you you see much more of a
clinical side of it and i feel like why
have people gone so mental like what
what is what switch has flipped in
people and actually this guy's that dog
explains it really clearly which is that
people
see everything through their moral
lenses
and it blocks their ability to see
reality clearly
and you'll be much more
attuned with with this i've not read the
righteous mind by jonathan height but he
talks about the different moral taste
buds and how each of those taste buds
touches a different part of our palate
and causes us to
swing to one side of the spectrum or the
other
and
when we've got
when we're faced with
two choices basically over the last
couple of years
it it makes for
a very
harsh swing and then obviously that's
reinforced by algorithms and echo
chambers and all of that stuff too so
i think having that maxim of just
realizing that people only see things
through their own moral lens gives you a
bit more compassion for
how people can get to such wacky
conclusions and this is wacky on both
sides of the fence right there are
people that are
so militantly pro vaccine and so
militantly anti-vaccine that both of
those stances
seem to lose a lot of the new ones
because like anything that you're 100 or
zero percent on is is inevitably
probably not because the world doesn't
operate in that nobody should be able to
say it at the very very best it's like
99.9 versus 0.01
like that's that's where it is at the
most extremes there's two
two quotes that come up that that make
me think about that
that um gowinder bogel
taught me that a lot of ridiculous
ideological views again moving away from
like vaccine stuff but just any
ridiculous ideological view or extreme
ideological view
is a signal of loyalty to your own side
and a signal of threat display to the
opposing side so it's not about the fact
that you believe or don't believe it's
that this is a badge of honor that you
need to wear in order to be a part of
our group and if you don't then we know
that there's something up with you
this is exactly it and so now even if
you
the the inner scientist in you says oh
okay
well based on the evidence i think this
is my conclusion if that betrays the
group that you're identifying with
suddenly
it's a problem you have to you you now
have a choice you have a moral choice of
loyalty versus betrayal
rather than
truth versus false which which is
ridiculous it also impacts your ability
to do sense making yourself right
that you don't know
your um emotions start to feed into your
own ability to be rational you go well i
don't actually know what i think about
this anymore
i i'm genuinely unable to separate out
what i think factually from what i feel
emotionally
well what's interesting is that
just to run through i've got the the six
moral taste buds here and as you hear
them you'll be like oh actually i can
see how
kovid will have completely
touched on everyone's trigger buttons
with each with each of these there's
care versus harm
fairness versus cheating
loyalty versus betrayal authority versus
subversion
sanctity versus degradation and liberty
versus oppression
it's all one of those big trigger
buttons for
yeah for people especially
101.
[ __ ] i've never read that i need to the
righteous mind sounds like a good um
a good one to add onto the endless list
of books that i'm never going to read i
i just assumed you had because you were
you know so
the jonathan hype book that i love is
the happiness hypothesis that's the one
that i got through this year which was
[ __ ] outstanding
yeah man that's um
that's a serious one that's a really
there's a guy
that posts on my that i've met a couple
times you know who he is yusuf we've met
him i'm not gonna say his name in my in
my mind not the person you're thinking
of
in my mind like a very intelligent guy i
was very daring brown quite uh yeah
quite
quite like middle of the road views and
all that sort of stuff but like
everything he posts at the moment is
basically comparing
um
the vaccine rollout to auschwitz
seriously and like making some really
and i'm saying this tobacco today like
it makes me
i can feel the things that he's posting
slowly make me think like
do i need to like reconsider how i feel
about all this stuff because this guy is
like so convinced and someone will ask
him a question beneath like just a
question
and he attacks them and then like all of
his friends like he attacked the person
too and you're like
what it like what has this guy seen that
he's convinced that this is
nazi germany and and i'm i've got my
booster book tomorrow like what is it
like how has this happened like these
are people who like
ostensibly totally normal
two years ago and suddenly something has
just pressed all the buttons the same
thing goes well the same thing goes for
people that are pro mandate i really
really struggle to understand how
somebody can be pro-mandating
a population to take
for for a disease which doesn't have the
anywhere near the sort of mortality that
you need to think about mandating
something for i use this example on a
debate which is never actually going to
get aired but i said can you imagine
give yourself a
thought experiment where this disease
has 100 mortality of all females
would you support a vaccine mandate in
that case it's like everybody would
everybody would say yeah the army gets
to come in and hold you the [ __ ] down
because the alternative is the end of
human civilization and every female on
the planet dies so it's not a difference
of kind it is just a difference of
degree i understand that there's a
spectrum but we're nowhere near the
threshold that that should have so for
me to think like what does it
what is it like for someone to believe
that you should mandate
people to take a medical procedure to
get a vaccine i'm like [ __ ] hell like
that's another situation that i can't
get my head around but people have gone
down both of these rabbit holes well and
the fact that you've now shied away from
100
on either side you're kind of somewhere
in the middle now well now you're the
enemy of everyone oh yeah that's the sam
harris problem right that out on the
extremes you get agreement from your own
side but in the middle you get
disagreement from both
like i think james smith posted
something on his story the other day
about like it's fine to not get the
vaccine but if you end up in a bed and i
see you then you're a
expletive
um and everybody like jumped on him um i
was like how dare you say that like that
doesn't just saying like
because what's he saying there really
actions have consequences that's yeah
that's all you're saying i think
everybody would agree that like
a lot of people who don't smoke get
annoyed that like smokers take up a lot
of hospital care or that you know that's
why there's like extra taxes on these
things
but people don't like that argument when
it's applied to something that's like a
choice that you you get a text from
chris whitley about it and you know
you're like it's bomb but it's all over
the tv it feels i mean people keep on
bringing up and rightly so people
continue to use the uh
fat people
there's most of the people that getting
hospitalized are overweight or a lot of
the people that have huge co-morbidities
are overweight should we penalize people
that are fat when they decide to go into
the nhs as well and the only real
difference that you can see again it's
not a difference of kind it's just a
difference of degree is that the
decision to be
thin
takes a lot of time whereas the decision
to take a vaccine is an immediate one so
all that it is is just the ease the
people that are pro
that are saying
um
somebody that is uh unvaccinated
shouldn't be given this hospital bed but
the person that's fat should be given
this hospital bed with their [ __ ]
diabetes to lose their leg or whatever
it is that they're getting the only
difference that that person has there in
their head is that getting fat is
something that's far easier to do
somehow and it happens over time i don't
know
that's the kind of thing they ask in med
school interviews like you've got three
patients and two beds you know one of
them's a child with cancer one of them
is a convict that's come out of prison
for doing this and he's a smoker and
then the third one's a heroin addict
like which one do you give the bed to
and what's the
relative like life extension that you
can
provide for each of these people and
you've got to kind of talk through the
different
moral um decision making matrices it's
like the
trolley problem with ai
you're like who do you run over
but like the people who um
you know people say are like it
you know fat people are the problem
because they like they shouldn't be fat
i think it's the you know if it was
suddenly everybody who has less than
five thousand pounds in their current
account dies of curvid or everybody who
gets less than seven hours of sleep dies
of curvid or everything you know you
could pick everyone's got a thing that
they're a bit [ __ ] at that comes down to
like
but
that
like is poorly managed but you know that
might be someone who's overweight but is
very successful financially or has a
really immaculate house or you know
whatever so you just like pick something
that happens to be the thing that you're
not go oh it's all their fault and
that's that's their problem that's a
good way to
a good way to put it the thing that the
most annoying
group and this is it doesn't matter
whether you're pro or anti-vaccine or
the people that are so militant to jump
on debates online like those are the
people that kovid should have got
those are the ones that it should have
[ __ ] killed the people that decide to
take the most extremist outlandish like
totally bombastic view and immediately
start
spurting out their opinion whether it's
well informed or not bro
this is not the hill that i want to
[ __ ] die on so get out of my comment
section like i do not care enough and
and people think that this is this is
some sort of a stand that you're really
really going to give a [ __ ] about it's
like dude i don't give a [ __ ] about your
half-baked cod psychology opinion about
why this is actually happening to be
drawn into this thing that's actually
like there are bigger problems in our
day-to-day lives that we need to
sort out sort your [ __ ] relationship
with your daughter out like how about
that
how about that there it is the
williamson surgical
surgical rinse
surgical incision moving on johnny what
have you got scalpel out
um
ma so one of the things i realized this
year was that and this is a business i
guess this only really applies to
business owners i suppose um
some of our like best weeks and months
were either when
i wasn't online at all so i was away or
i worked less for whatever reason which
makes me feel like i make things worse
firstly like when i'm trying hard it it
is worse um but also just i think a
reminder
that
um
i guess like as a
i think i've heard
heard jeff bezos say like he considers
himself to be paid to make like one to
three decisions a day like one to three
high quality decisions a day and i think
as some if you're in charge of something
either in charge of a team or you're in
your own business or whatever you're
trying to do like really the thing that
you
that moves you forward is just having a
few hours of like clear
energy-filled headspace to make some
decisions and do a few key things and
actually like constantly trying to push
the boulder up the hill all the time
often just makes it worse
and i'm always
we had a quote that you said you'll know
that what i'm referring to that was a
business mentor of ours said something
like you know you as a business owner
you're like a
you're like someone in the sas you're
like in through in through the window
kill the target and get out again like
don't like sit on the sofa for five
hours and i think it's so easy to
do fill your fill your days with things
that don't necessarily matter when it's
just
the few things you could have done do
you think that this is a byproduct of
people that are small business owners
and entrepreneurs that have started
things from the ground floor up because
they have that sort of um
firefighter putting out the small
problems operations first i'm going to
do the logistics i'm going to fix the
problem like that's what all three of us
have grown up running businesses as the
guy that the book stops with and i i
wonder how much of that is is kind of
programming from from how we came up
yeah
for the first couple of years of us
running propane like we were doing the
marketing the accounts the the delivery
the
making the logo
like posting on facebook or just
literally like you are the entire hr you
know you're the entire
suite of departments aren't you as
when i have a problem i email hr which
is yusuf and then he forwards it to me
to deal with to deal with it
they've got like a toxic culture problem
in uh
culture it's horrendous yeah um it's
awful awful place to work but yeah like
so this idea that like monday having a
busy month an overly busy monday working
too long on too many hours on a monday
impacts your tuesday which impacts your
wednesday and i think just as woo as it
sounds
protecting the the energy in the the the
head space you have above other things
because actually doing like two hours of
focused work on something or even just
two hours of thinking in a day
is more important than spending all day
in your inbox i can't remember who it
was
sorry go ahead
no no that was it i i can't remember who
it was that said that
if you look at the role of a business
owner or a ceo like specifically what
they actually do
they're a hard to replicate complex
decision engine
so that's what the the value is that's
why the person at the very very top of
the tree gets paid so much because they
can aggregate all of this data both
objective subjective
qualitative quantitative the felt sense
all of that stuff right they just
aggregate all of this [ __ ] that's going
on and they like
and they just spurt out a single answer
at the end of it and the presumption is
that that answer is the right one like
that they're a complex a hard to
replicate complex decision engine and
that is why
you know as you go further and further
down the chain of command people are
it's easier to find a cleaner that knows
how to clean than it is to find a ceo
that knows how to ceo because that
cleaners skills are more replaceable
than the ceos are because they're very
very specialized into this particular
business at this particular point in
time within that market within this
nation within these market conditions
blah blah blah blah blah
yeah
yeah
all right uh my one my one
so this was from
a fail actually from this year it's a
lesson from a fail so my personal goal
for this year was to reduce my screen
time on my phone
and buy any metric that you want to
choose like i just haven't done it i
haven't been able to
to reduce screen time uh by a
substantive amount i i did it for the
first quarter and then maybe for the
first half of the year i was making okay
progress and then that just turned into
not okay progress and then while i was
out in texas
that screen time ticked up more because
i was spending more time uh like away
from other people which meant that in
order to get in contact with him blah
blah blah
and
it came back to realizing while i was
away in texas although screen time had
ticked up while i was in the house
overall it actually gone down and
that reminded me that focus on building
a life that creates the habits you want
so you can turn notifications off on
your phone and sleep with your phone
outside of your bedroom and go grayscale
and do all of the things right and do
all of the things
or
you can live a life that makes you not
want to look at your phone
like you can try and
use james clear's motivation framework
in order to build up a habit of going to
the gym and you'll do one push-up today
and two push-ups tomorrow and blah blah
blah or you can just find a training
regime that you really really enjoy in a
group of people that you want to do it
with
and you're going to go to the gym as a
byproduct of the life that you've
created i think a lot of the time we
take a very uh like hermetically sealed
semi-autistic view of the solution to do
this which is to kind of brute force it
through the correct process or whatever
it might be but people have fluked
the same outcome the same sort of
process built life outcome that you're
looking for simply by the life that they
go through you know there'll be tons and
tons of people out there who are very
very fit simply because they play a team
sport that they love and they can't
imagine not playing that team sport like
they have created a life that builds the
habits that they want and a lot of the
time it isn't even about habits like we
don't know the habits that we really
really want it's that we have an outcome
goal that we want and we presume that
those habits are going to get us toward
it it's like i want to be fit i want to
be stronger i want to look good i want
to do whatever okay there are a million
[ __ ] ways that you could get through
that i want to earn more money i want to
do whatever it is that your goal is
just trying to create a life that helps
foster that you know who are the people
that you're spending your time around
what's the sort of daily routine that
you've got what are the sort of things
that you consume in terms of news
sources and content and stuff like that
those things will direct your life far
more i think than trying to or at least
equally as much as trying to brute force
your way through some habit process
quite hard to compete with the guy who's
having fun
correct
correct it's what it's what like
crossfit does for most people right like
you know you see crossfitters who are
just shredded and
really strong and they don't even really
train they don't like they don't really
do anything with their diet or like
train for strength necessarily they just
love crossfit and like five years later
they're in great condition with their
minds and fit and mobile they just enjoy
crossfit and it's very
i think yeah it's finding the
the the difficulty is because of phone i
think for a lot of people
me included is this like it's a filler
thing
it's not you know when people say oh
like what it was justif's point of you
know look how many hours you have on
your screen time and that's time you
could be spent doing something else
it feels because you don't have the four
hours or whatever screen time in a chunk
at the start of the day it feels very
hard to
say i'm going to stop that
so it's a
crossfit's the perfect example of that
because
you've got someone who like
crossfit programming is chaotic by by
definition
but
if you just nail it and just train
really hard and do a lot of stuff
spend more time doing the actual thing
then you're going to outperform someone
who's like meticulously trying to like
over optimizes programming but practice
there
right writing something
yeah but actually they just do crossfit
you you had the best uh life hack around
this usef which is to have a different
holding pattern activity we all have
those moments where we're waiting for 90
seconds
for something what is it that we default
to and almost always it's i'll get my
phone out of my pocket i'll pick my
phone up it's frightening because that
has got to be such a large chunk of our
screen time yeah you're waiting for
you're waiting in the line at the
supermarket what is it that you default
to you're waiting jumping jacks yeah
well
just thinking of something else that you
could have so for me it's been the
solution for that has been to put a
kindle on my desk
so for instance exporting the amount of
time it takes me probably about an hour
a week to export files
of different manners maybe even more
actually maybe sort of upwards of two
hours and it just means that when i
export files now i just get i get the
kindle out and i'll just read whatever's
on there so that's a new holding pattern
activity problem is that i don't have
the kindle with me when i'm in a
supermarket or when i'm waiting to get
my tires changed at [ __ ] quick fit or
whatever it might be
um
i had a client who used to
once a week he would
move the kindle app on his phone to
where his instagram was
so he would like you know you find
it's amazing so like you'll move
something like i've really i've really
tricked myself here i've hidden it in a
folder on the third screen then before
you know it you've got this like slick
move where you flick to the folder and
open instagram before you know what's
happened yes but if just once a week you
just have a reminder to just move kindle
to where instagram is yeah before you
know it you're in kindle yeah you've got
to keep like out doing yourself yeah so
i think like you could view it as well
how to imagine if i turned a third of my
screen time into reading time like is
screen time still bad no well that's the
problem that's what uh tristan harris
says exclusively right his issue isn't
with screen time it's with what screen
time is used for yeah if you could have
it
be really mindful and have people's
retrospective uh assessments of how they
spent their screen time be really really
happy and whatever but it's not
for the most part when people look back
on the way that they spent their time on
their phone
they don't feel too good about it they
don't feel like it added very much to
their life they don't i mean [ __ ]
when me and george were in dubai last
year
there was a girl who showed us her
screen time and it was 12 hours a day
consistently 12 hours a day and eight
hours of that was on tick tock
unbelievable there was a four hour
session on tick tock one time
so
did she do it while she was eating or
does she
i can't remember it's i it made me feel
so uncomfortable that i had to exit the
conversation
tic toc is some kind of psy ops from
china what to down regulate what
everyone say it wouldn't surprise me i
mean whilst we are spending eight hours
a day on tick tock china is restricting
their under 18s to only be able to play
video games between eight and nine pm
three days a week
yeah they're up to something it feels
like they know something we don't yeah
i've heard um i think we've discussed
frank yang before he's a guy that used
to be like he was a fitness youtuber got
really into meditation like really way
off the deep end but he's he's been like
loads of retreats does multiple hours
meditation a day and um i've heard him
talk about breaking he has completed it
heard him talk about breaking bad habits
or trying to like adjust his behavior
and how he tried for years to stop like
random arbitrary things and that that he
always felt like that was just changing
the
what was on the screen
like it's just it's changing the channel
but it's still there's still a tv with a
with a there's something playing and
actually have to change the screen
itself or like become the screen
i'm guessing that meditation was his
solution for that yeah so but
that feels to me like the
if there's like the master reset of like
i want to stop looking at my phone how
do i handle that it's like well
surely becoming aware of the
process of picking my phone up is the
way to do it but that's like a fat
multi-thousand hour process right yes
yeah
creating a life where you you often go
and do something fun that makes you not
look at your phone might be a quicker
solution at least either way yeah
alongside okay so we said that we were
also going to get a life hack a favorite
life hack or two that we'd had from the
year and uh go through those did you get
did you both choose one or two yes
i was geared up for a final reflection
of the
year
so this is one that i've learned from
johnny because
johnny is an absolute [ __ ] with opting
into
people's marketing funnels and
all that kind of thing
yeah
i love it i just love it so much
sticky
email sequences all over my face
exactly
and
the the lesson from that is actually
this is really valuable that if you
observe how you buy things that teaches
you how to sell because quite often we
we work with personal trainers
to move online and help them with their
online marketing
and quite often you'll see people like
make their first attempt at marketing
and you're like whoa
weird like why are they suddenly gone
from being a normal person to just
suddenly really weird and it's because
they think it's this like different
special
skill and special voice that you have to
put on and all this stuff and actually
if you
just notice how you buy things and what
it is that causes you to buy or what
causes you to opt into someone's funnel
and then at some point to be like oh
right that's it i'm buying it like and
noticing those moments
then you're like oh well
it's very clear now because you see the
internal problems forming and then
looking for a solution and finding who
is able to solve that problem for you
and then you buy
so
yeah the opting into marketing funnels
and email analysts and things can be
valuable that's slightly different
though right because what johnny's doing
there is seeing how other people do
things that's not necessarily based on
why he buys but i think that that's like
an amazing
solution for somebody that wants to sell
something
you are the business the business is
going to need to reflect your
personality at least
in part because that's what's going to
make it unique so why not if you're the
person that you're selling to or you're
the person that's writing it
why not try and think about what
triggers you to buy
yeah and you you're right it's a
slightly different
habit i suppose
other people out there might not want to
sign up to 10 email sequences a week
just so that you can see if there's any
good funnel hacking secrets in there
i kind of i just kind of believe that
you should
like
to participate in the in the system that
you want to
benefit from so like i allow everything
to track me
no ad blockers i allow every app to
track opt into everything buy buy buy
from other coaches
i just think the more i give the system
the more it'll give back to me that's
you've got a full [ __ ] lunar science
energy
proven sciences the other thing there is
that you do see people who are like they
hit hit a certain level with their
advancement of training and they go oh
i'm not hiring a coach me because i'm
dead advanced or not it's like
what's your job again coach okay so
eric helms pointed this out to us he was
like put your hand up if you if you have
a coach and like some people did and he
was like okay so the people that don't
what you're saying there is that
what you do as a job has no value
it's like yeah
[ __ ]
yeah
right right right right then
let's
[ __ ] let's go
on
let's go on uh life hacks let's go life
hacks
johnny
i've had a problem what's the problem
so i keep all my life hacks in an
omnifocus list
and normally you can see the things that
have been
ticked however recently because i have
so many things in my omnifocus they have
to be archived and you can't access
i can't work out how to access the
archive i do however have i'm not sure
whether i've mentioned this but i have
one that's top of mind that i can say
hit it how about that
have i mentioned
moments
on the waking up app before
no yes
maybe
so i think i think i may have said it to
yusuf but i don't think i've life hacked
it formally
formal submission formal submission for
lifehacks so sam harris's app waking up
which i think we must have mentioned
before two cool things about it one
i think this is something i said to you
ages ago chris but i wish that there was
like a wrong one for meditation like a
daily session for meditation samara says
something some arises
horace's app has that which is the first
cool thing the second thing it has is
something called moments which is
at random if you turn it on at random
into intervals throughout the day
it prompts you with a push notification
to listen to like a one minute audio to
just help you like
improve the general mindfulness in your
day so it might be like spending a
minute thinking about death for example
which i know sounds incredibly morbid
but actually when you're like stressed
about something or like caught up in a
task you're like actually you know what
it's not really that important
very very useful and they're always
random so it'll be like at 10 am or
just before you go to bed or whatever if
you just have a commitment to yourself
that no matter what it is when it is
i'll just listen to the one minute thing
it's so useful you get to choose how
many moments you have per day right
i don't think so
i think it's just all on sam
insane we trust
alright i thought that you got to choose
well i so i've signed up to waking up
i've been using it my meditation
practice been all over this year so i
signed up to to waking up i actually
bought one of my mom's christmas
presents was a year's membership to
waking up as well
oh that's brilliant
so it's just you can choose when you
have the moments from so starting it
yeah nine and ending ten and then you
can turn it on and turn it off that
doesn't do it at 3am like wake up right
think about this
give them give me a [ __ ] health sam
mate it's 3am
uh cool johnny's apple watch that said
it's 4am you've been sat down too long
uh so i uh
two of mine of my favorite life hacks of
the year these weren't supposed to be
new ones but i appreciate the new one uh
two of mine are actually johnny
submitted life hacks which is if there
was ever
a better way to show that the lifehacks
system works it's that i do
things and they're the most valuable
things and i've taken them from the show
uh so my
two of my favorites from this year were
uh use creatine tablets to avoid ever
dosing your creatine
like it's an absolute game changer yeah
johnny's doing like french man's kiss
it is it's bellissimo i know that's not
real it's not french uh yeah it's just
such a hack
remembering to put creatine two scoops
strawberry remembering to put that in
your shake is impossible but having the
tablet it just goes in with everything
else do you forget to take your
multivitamin no you do not do you forget
to take your creatine yes you do okay
put the tablets
personally if you want to do this the uh
micronized creatine
from my protein come in plastic capsules
which are much more
comfortable to swallow than the
normal creatine which is uncoated and
kind of like horse
big horse tablet thing you're nodding
like you know the problem johnny it's
like trying to swallow a biscuit isn't
it if they're big you can't they're big
old boys well they're one gram each disc
um so the first one was creatine tablets
and the second one is clearway to think
that only a year ago
i didn't use clearway
is
unbelievable it's it's the best protein
that i've ever found in my entire life
by
by
so far the thinking about all of the
time that we've had
like milky it's a how how do you even
make something milky when it's mixed
with water like how is that even
possible and now you have this whole new
world which is juice
it's so there we are creatine tablets in
clearway my top two from this year
jonathan watson thank you very much
supplements have come such a long way
like do you remember casein caseinate
this was not not micellar casein that's
the new generation two much nicer still
still tastes like sand but casein hasn't
it was a lump of clay in your shaker and
you'd shake it and it would go
on the top and bottom of your thing i've
thrown that up so many times now it's
like when people describe like malibu
and they say oh i can't drink malibu
anymore because i had a i had a bad
vomiting experience
it's like that casein casonate is the
same for you
we could have put some blueberry extract
in it which would have
fixed all of you probably
garlic and mushroom extract
with some apple fiber or something yeah
awesome horny goat weed right what's
yours what have you got
this actually won't apply to people who
have listened this far into the episode
but
one of my big difficulties with podcasts
is
people recommend some to me like oh
great i'll stick it on the list
but then
with the previous apps i used to use it
was a linear queue and so if you skip
the episode you can't go back to wait to
pick up where you left off
so i've started using spotify now for
podcasts and the my episodes feature is
great because the search feature on
spotify is second to none
you can search for episode or
or show and it comes up on the thing and
then you can just say one button bang it
into my episodes
then you have a cue that you can kind of
tap ass so it keeps your spot in all the
episodes you've been listening to so
you don't have to abandon an episode
forever if you if you want to nudge
something up the queue and come back to
it or if you're like oh you know what
i'm not really in the mood to listen to
an existential crisis uh interview today
but i want to hear the latest life hacks
from fitness and modern wisdom that you
know it's it's like
then you can kind of dip in an art so
spotify for podcasts
brilliant dude
it's [ __ ] great
like i i'm still not fully over from
apple podcasts but that's more habitual
than it is platform limiting now
i've not used the apple podcast up in
years but i see people on like the
forums just furious about it being like
how come like this still isn't
bug still isn't fixed and it's still so
true they're trying to go deeper as well
they're putting subscribers so you can
have through apple pay
you can um
gate
subscriber-only content for paid members
um
and you so you've got like an internal
way to create whatever patreon and stuff
like that you think why not improve the
search function apple
uh but anyone that is listening anyone
that is listening especially if you're
on spotify but even if you're not if
you've got spotify on your phone open
spotify go to modern wisdom and give us
five stars please because they've just
enabled reviews
on spotify for podcasts so if you can go
and give us five sites you don't even
have to write anything there's not even
a space to write something so just go
and give us five stars because for a
very long time i've worked quite hard to
build up the apple podcast reviews and
now i have a new platform that i need to
try and dominate so go do that right
it's a separate ecosystem for reviews
then they don't link with the feed or
with
no i don't know it's just
it's like how many subscribers have you
got on youtube that doesn't correlate
with how many subscribers you've got on
spotify or whatever yeah totally
separate
we probably have never mentioned this as
a life hack but spotify in general
spotify premium i think is worth every
penny like i think i would pay
10 times the amount to retain my access
to spotify dude youtube premium youtube
premium is as much better as pakistani
it's association
a vpn and you get it for 17p yeah that's
argentinian it's 89p uh it's it's as big
of a change so here's the thing right
this is whatever it was the negative
pilot you really only know about the
gains that you've made in life when you
see someone else that doesn't have those
gains or when you revert back to a lower
resolution version of life that has you
without that
when you go onto someone's spotify on
their phone and you realize that they
don't have premium so i was in the gym
hey it's billy eilish you're listening
to the top hits danny was really happy
with the house that he found in gosforth
yeah what's the volume of the song we
were [ __ ] in in the on it gym the
other day and the coach that had the
music on was was getting [ __ ] pinged
with like clavio ads part way through
clavio believes that you need to own
your customer data and you know right
that that is how it feels to me when i
watch someone on youtube
press
on a video and then them have to skip
two ads of seven seconds in length
disgusting
it violates my principle which is
participate in the system that you want
to benefit from
so if i run youtube ads why aren't you
running spotify ads then
i mean i've just never even explored it
if you started running spotify ads would
you feel that you had to cancel that's
right
good question
good
question not sure probably i would be
there i'd be at an an impasse
i wouldn't know what to do
maybe do like one month on one month off
or something like that periodize it
perfect solution yeah uh gentlemen
go on what are you saying
well i didn't do my thing about the
program
oh so tell us your thing about the
program come on hit us
okay
it's okay
well neither of you have probably seen
have you ever either have you seen don't
look up on netflix
i actually have
[ __ ] kidding me
yes how have you seen it and i haven't
seen it i'm so current
as someone that hasn't seen it what i've
heard is that it's
a a comment against the
sort of woke progressive crazy climate
activism world and that people are
feeling very satisfied by watching it
and it's also fun
and and funny
so interestingly i
got to the end of it i was having a
shower afterwards
and i thought
i really need to do more
on the like the climate change front
really seriously wow
yeah
i'm i'm unable to comment here i can't
say anything i'm just like [ __ ] to be
honest i'm i'm also not sure how
that was a conclusion
so i think you know you said you've seen
it yeah
so
throughout it i imagine you had this
underlying sense of slight frustration
that no one was taking the people
seriously
and they're all going like hello
everybody have you seen like this
massive problem everyone's going like
and i think like what my view of what's
that's trying to get across is that like
we're in that situation now it's just
less
defined and clear yes and the only only
actually towards the end of the program
trying to spoil it for chris only
towards the end of the program does it
become obvious and clear and then
everyone's like ah well i mean the same
so why don't we if if that's the case if
we're concerned about climate change
what the [ __ ] about artificial
intelligence
that's one that you literally can't see
and is irreversible
so it's the it's honestly it could be
relating to any of them yeah
i thought existential risk at large yeah
covered
i thought that's what they were
commenting on initially because there's
a lot of parallels with coverage with
trump or leonardo leonardo
is big in the old climate change world
right he didn't use it his oscar
or golden globe uh speech a little while
ago to just point his finger at people
that
drive cars or something
he was basically the reason i watched it
i think like you you jonah hills jonah
hill's [ __ ] pretty big dick as well
most of this stuff is good but leonardo
dicaprio doesn't make very many films
like it's quite rare that leonardo
dicaprio
he's not nicholas cage is he yeah or
like a bruce willis who's still or um
liam neeson who's just
pumping him out quality is just just
dropping and dropping like guys just
stop just [ __ ] give it up
but yeah
i don't know um
the triple a is like
what do you do about ai
that's that's the defeatist attitude
that everybody has about it well they
don't know okay so lobby
what we really need is to lobby for
oversight the same way as we have with
regards to nuclear weapons the same way
as we have now to do with syn bio so
synthetic bio uh biology and bio weapons
you can't
sequence the genome of a
known pathogen on a tabletop
creator and anything which is slightly
dangerous gets sent up for review
so the way that it works is that someone
can't just buy a genome sequencer and
then [ __ ] create recreate smallpox
right download the smallpox genome from
the internet and then recreate it you
can't do that because you have oversight
from a central body now we need
something that's
so much more
serious than that to do with the
research around
ai because the control problem which is
how do you make sure that the ai does
the thing that you want it to do and not
turn you all into paper clips that needs
to be fixed before you have the ai but
the incentives are completely reversed
to that the incentives are okay we get
the ai we make it work
and we'll deal with the problems when it
arises because the it's winners
thing to do at the time precisely
there's the problem of like i can't
remember who spoke about this but the
idea that like you're building a house
and when you lay the foundations and you
build the first layer and you build a
first layer it all looks fine completely
fine no problems no one flags it and
then you get like 20 stories up and
you're like oh [ __ ] that thing that we
did on level two
everything's gonna collapse and you only
realize once you're 20 levels up that
the thing that you built so there would
be some cost fallacy to programmers that
realize that they may be well no it's
just it's just too late so like the
approval process that everything gets
approved approved to prove like oh my
god the thing that seemed fine
is now and then it's a big [ __ ] it's
a big [ __ ] problem and not enough
people are talking about it anyway
gentlemen 2021
we've completed it i literally actually
genuinely have deleted it uh thank you
for joining me this year on some awesome
episodes lots and lots of life hacks
lots coming up as well over the next
couple of weeks uh guests that everyone
can expect stephen pinker
uh andrew hubermann
bridget fettesey
uh
can't say a couple of other ones because
i haven't announced them yet but they
will be
very very very large and i'm looking
forward to it but thank you you will
continue to be a staple part of the
furniture uh people want to check out
what it is that you do where should they
go
propanefitness.com
if you want a calculator for fat loss
and stuff propanefitness.com forward
slash modern wisdom if you want to build
an online business
i love it gentlemen happy new year merry
chrimbo and
thank you to hospital
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you